- We've already talked
about the 14th Amendment
in previous videos,
but just as a reminder,
Section 1 of the 14th Amendment says,
"All persons born or naturalized
in the United States,
"and subject to the jurisdiction thereof,
"are citizens of the United States
"and of the State wherein they reside.
"No State shall make or enforce any law
"which shall abridge the
privileges or immunities
"of citizens of the United States;
"nor shall any State deprive any person
"of life, liberty, or property,
"without the due process of law;
"nor deny to any person
within its jurisdiction
"the equal protection of the laws."
And this last clause,
which I just underlined,
the Equal Protection Clause,
has been cited many times,
not just in social justice movements
but in many Supreme Court cases.
And what we're going to do in this video
is think about how rulings
by the Supreme Court
represent both continuity over time,
but also change over
time, especially relative
to the protection of minority rights.
One of the most significant test cases
of the 14th Amendment
happens almost 30 years
after the amendment is ratified in 1896.
This is a situation where
the state of Louisiana
passes a law that African American people
have to sit in a separate
railcar from white people.
And so you have this gentleman here,
Homer Plessy, a resident of New Orleans,
who decides to test this law.
He sits in a white only car,
and he is 1/8 African American.
And he gets arrested.
This case eventually goes to
the United States Supreme Court,
and they rule that the Louisiana law
requiring separate cars
is not unconstitutional
as long as the cars
are judged to be equal.
And this is where that term
"separate but equal" comes from.
And this is viewed as a
fairly infamous ruling
because it was the
Supreme Court reinforcing
this idea of segregation, even after
the 14th Amendment had been
passed almost 30 years prior.
Now, we go almost 60 years in the future
in order for segregation to be challenged
in a very significant way.
Then we get to the case of Brown versus
Board of Education of
Topeka, Kansas in 1954,
in which the then Supreme Court
rules that "No, segregation is not okay.
"Separate is inherently unequal."
And this right over here is a picture
of a desegregated
classroom around that time
although this is not in Topeka, Kansas.
But it shows how based
on the passage of time,
based on social norms, based on a change
in the make-up of the Supreme Court,
how they can make rulings
that go one way or the other.
Plessy versus Ferguson
reaffirms segregation.
It's perceived to curtail minority rights
while Brown versus Board of
Education goes the other way.
Once again, taking a look
at the 14th Amendment.
Now, if we fast-forward to 1993,
we have another really interesting
test case, Shaw versus Reno.
This is a situation where
after the 1990 census
North Carolina takes a look
at its congressional districts
and sends them to review by
the federal Justice Department.
The federal Justice Department decides
that the first pass
that North Carolina took
at the districting only had one
black majority congressional district.
And they thought that there could be
two black majority
congressional districts.
So, the state of North
Carolina redistricted again,
and they created this 12th district here,
which you can see is
kind of a strange shape.
It's strung along over 160 miles
in this very thin district.
Now, this was taken to the Supreme Court
by citizens of North Carolina saying that
this districting was a severe
case of gerrymandering,
which we've talked about in other videos,
and should be deemed unconstitutional.
And the Supreme Court
actually did rule in 1993
that redistricting purely
on the basis of race,
as was done in this situation,
even though it was with the intent
of having more minority representation
in Congress, that this
type of redistricting
on the basis of race was unconstitutional.
This Supreme Court also cited
the Equal Protection Clause
and also cited the 14th Amendment saying,
"Look, once you start redistricting
"based on racial lines, it creates a type
"of racial separation,
which is unconstitutional
"by the 14th Amendment."
So, these are really good cases to know.
They show how the Supreme Court
can rule differently depending
on what time period we are in
or depending on the circumstance.
That often times when we think about
equal protection, we think about
protection of minority rights.
But as we saw in the
case of Shaw versus Reno,
even when the intent of, in
this case gerrymandering,
is to give more minority representation,
it was deemed unconstitutional
because from the Supreme Court's
point of view violated the 14th Amendment.